major breaking news surrounding the
politization of the fbi whistleblowers
now fighting back against the rampant
political bias in their own ranks
according to a new bombshell report from
the washington times top fbi agent tim
tebow yeah like the quarterback was
reportedly escorted out of the
washington field office on friday but
two or three other agents
they took him out he's now accused of
quote political bias in handling the
investigation of hunter biden's computer
laptop now this is the high ranking
agent who allegedly attempted to slow
walk the hunter probe in 2020 now
tonight fox news has confirmed that
tebow is no longer with the bureau we
did reach out to the fbi for a statement
they declined to comment former
president trump he's speaking out
blasting the bias and abuse of the fbi
quote tonight sadly we have seen this
before former top agent by the way peter
strzok was also once escorted out of the
fbi bureau you might remember for
political bias remember prior to the
2016 presidential election
he texted his colleague his lover lisa
page said he had a plan to stop trump
from ever becoming president will stop
him he also texted about an insurance
policy of her policy that they discussed
in andy's office didn't work in other
words the russia hoax to smear slander
besmirch donald trump in the unlikely
event that he does become president
first to of course to prevent him from
ever becoming president after he was
fired from the bureau strzok was
rewarded with a lucrative book deal and
numerous appearances on fake news cnn
msdnc where far-left political bias is
revered and admired and the anti-trump
witch hunts at the fbi never stopped
director ray failed this country and
this brings us to the mar-a-lago raid
despite heavy redactions from the doj
and the affidavit we can now see that
the fbi relied on speculative news
articles to justify their raid this is
insanity this is what the fbi has now
been reduced to quoting america's
abusively corrupt and biased news media
and remember which was arrayed in search
of documents requested by bureaucrats at
the national archives as the wall street
journal put a quote the mar-a-lago
affidavit
that's all there is the redacted 38
pages add to the evidence that the fbi
search was really all about a dispute
over documents and late last week
retired assistant director of the fbi
kevin brock he had this to say listen
closely
the fbi should not have participated in
this investigation
uh it was a
the earlier point was initiated by the
national archives it is something that
needs to be settled along established
routes in that regard that had been
traditionally used there was no need for
law enforcement involvement in this
and there was certainly no need for an
invasive search for the residence
i think they're going to regret this
you know many people even on the left
said if there's no smoking gun if
there's no real media violation here
this is that's right this is not going
to go well
in an op-ed brock declared that the doj
has no case against president trump and
now we're learning the fbi well quote
accidentally seized privileged documents
from the president's home during their
fishing expedition including
attorney-client material that law
enforcement is prohibited from ever
viewing ever in other words a very clear
violation of the fourth amendment that's
why you don't have broad sweeping
warrants like this one uh signed off by
a magistrate that hates trump loves
obama and already once recused himself
from a case involving donald trump but
the doj the fbi they don't want a
special master to review this case as
requested by president trump's attorneys
instead they simply want us to trust
them they already read it all anyway
they've had enough time including
material of president trump's that was
attorney client privileged this is the
same organization the same fbi that
brought you let's see uh andrew mccabe
and jim comey uh peter strzok lisa page
the russia collusion hoax the mueller
witch hunt the fisa court fraud and lies
to the fisa courts pre-dawn raids with
guns drawn 30 people at a time fake news
cnn cameras at roger stone's raid then
the paul manafort raid then other trump
associates the same organization that
let hillary clinton off the hook for
mishandling a ton of top secret and
classified materials on an unsecure
private server multiple servers actually
because according to comey no reasonable
prosecutor would bring a case the same
people that let her get away with clear
obstruction of justice deleting 33 000
emails going as far as to acid wash or
hard drive with bleach bit and
destroying any devices that might have
those emails with hammers and then
removing sim cards take a look although
we did not find clear evidence that
secretary clinton or her colleagues
intended to violate laws governing the
handling of classified information there
is evidence that they were extremely
careless
in their handling of very sensitive
highly classified information although
there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
oh laws were broken but no prosecutor
would charge her the organization that
led hillary off the hook is now the very
same organization that has been jumping
through hoops to protect zero experience
hunter biden and by his father who is
implicated in that laptop from hell
numerous times with evidence in fact
that joe biden your president knew
everything about hunter biden's foreign
business dealings and this is the same
organization that asked facebook we
didn't know this until well zuckerberg
just told us to trust them before the
election in 2020. watch this
there was a lot of attention on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new yeah
we chose to yeah so you guys censored
that as well so we took a different path
than twitter um i mean basically the
background here is the fbi i think
basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be
some kind of dump of of um
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant
be vigilant don't don't go with the
hunter biden story three weeks before a
presidential election and don't allow
people to get that information out there
because it might influence people's
voting the very real hunter biden laptop
was not russia propaganda not at all
trump hating officials now at the bureau
were lying to protect joe biden so that
donald trump would be defeated and of
course big tech and the media mob were
more than happy to comply
this is beyond an egregious and blatant
abuse of power on so many levels now
even late night liberal bill maher can
see the obvious truth of what they did
here and actually said it this weekend
take a look answer this question was it
appropriate the question is was it
appropriate to bury the hunter by
talking about the press doing that he's
saying that's what they did and that is
what they did they buried the hunter
biden story before the election because
they were like we can't risk having the
election thrown to trump we'll tell them
after the election and we know for a
fact that that's what they did of course
you know but i was saying you know for a
fact that that's what they do i don't
know what they did i know because you
only watch msnbc that's not true
that's not true well then you would know
about this
he said he watches fox news but he's
still a meathead this is why director
ray has done a grave disservice to what
should be the premier law enforcement
agency in the entire world he should
have cleaned it up he didn't and getting
away with everything has now led to more
politics at the fbi he needs to be
replaced and by the way so should the
attorney general he should be impeached
now bill maher and i we don't agree on
much but he's at least honest give him
credit according to one poll one in six
americans would not have voted for joe
biden had they known the laptop scandal
was real one in six that's it game over
trump won 2020 with those numbers now
democrats in the media they don't care
so
many on the left have literally shunned
logic all truth they don't care if in
2016 they lie about russia collusion
that didn't happen they spread it as
though it's gospel truth then when you
really have laptop with information that
is damning to a democratic candidate oh
that's russian disinformation when in
fact it was anything but and they do
that to malign donald trump and anyone
that supports him and many by the way
still believe that their
uh very own lies with the russia hoax
that it was not a hoax at all many have
no idea that joe and hunter sold access
to our federal government to china to
russia to ukraine to other countries
that by the way are hostile regimes that
don't like our country and don't seem to
care at all about the level of
corruption for them it's a means to an
end destroy trump at all costs right on
cue at msdnc a pundit who claimed the
hunter biden laptop was russian
disinformation has now been tapped by
joe biden to serve on the intelligence
advisory board that needs to be stopped
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else